[Music]
i know
most people don't think about us up
there in the mountains
many of my patients are minors it's
dangerous work and i carry the burden of
building this nation on their backs
they're okay
these people my people
trusted me
i can't believe how many of them are
good now
we began looking at something that could
be big oxycontin
purdue pharma they've been marketing the
drug as something that's non-addictive
when it clearly is all your doctors are
going to be asking how is this even
possible your most effective talking
point are these magic words
less than one percent less than one
percent less than one less than one it
told me that less than one percent would
become addicted
foxy cotton does what i think it can
it could soon become purdue's first
billion dollar drug
purdue continues to lie about the drug
safety
doctors the patients and the fda
be the major case here
addiction rates overdoses and crime
are on the rise across the country
because of this drug
i think maybe the
medicine might be just a tad more
addictive than you said
i can't live like this anymore
our community is ground zero for a
national catastrophe
purdue will not move unless we punch
heart
this is not our fault these people want
to be addicted
i want top executives to feel some pain
it's crucial they understand we've
created the greatest painkiller in the
history of human civilization
[Music]
i think i can make this the biggest drug
in the world
[Music]
you